oh I'm Bing I'm awesome you're nobody
nobody cares about you you're wrong
garbage whatever but then this is quite
mimetic right so people started picking
this up and tweeting about it but Bing
has access to search so Bing would start
looking up people eliciting this
underlined Sydney variant of Bing and
that would immediately re induce Sydney
in bing so Bing became this sort of
complex system that wasn't just you know
this thing sitting on a server at
Microsoft it was that thing sitting on
the server at Microsoft and access to
the search Eng
and then entangled with everybody on
Twitter interacting with Bing so you
quite quickly had sort of a
core very weak but still quite powerful
AI system that quite quickly became the
sort of weird embedded extended
intelligence and I expect that this will
continue to happen like early agis may
have humans in the loop to take care of
physical stuff that they can't do or